the uh the gates of uh paradise are open
and the gates of hell are closed. Does
this mean that we will be going to
paradise if we die in this blessed
month? This again is the same question
of the same hadith. Same hadith which I
quoted earlier of Musnad Ahmed verse
number two page number 230 had number
7148 and it also appears in sunai
chapter number 5 hadith number 21106
again the same hadith the prophet said
he told the people that the blessed
month of Ramadan is approaching and
Allah has ordained for you that you fast
in this month and in this month the
gates of heaven will be open and the
gates of hell will be closed and the
devils will be chained in this month is
the night of kadar which is more blessed
than a thousand months and a person
who's deprived of the pleasures of the
blessings in this month is truly a
deprived person. Here again this is a
common question that if the gates of
heaven open and the gates of hell are
closed then anyone who dies but
naturally go to Jenna because the gates
of hell closed and Jenna open does it
mean that even if a non-Muslim dies in
this month even he'll have to go to
Jenna. The reply to this question is
when Allah says that in this month of
Ramadan the gates of heaven are open it
means the gates of heaven are inviting
you to enter
ja that means that even if you do a
small deed Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
will multiply your reward and as the
prophet said that every deed will get a
reward 10
times and in this month it's very easy
to enter Jenna. When a prophet said the
gates of hell will be closed, indicating
that to enter hell is difficult in this
month. Why? Because the tawa level
rises and the chances of you to commit
sin is less. And furthermore, if you
fast the full month in the month of
Ramadan seeking Allah's reward, all your
past sins will be forgiven. So the
moment a person fast in this complete
month of Ramadan seeking Allah's reward
all his past sins are completely
forgiven. So if the past sins are
forgiven the chances of him going to
hell is
nil. But what we have to realize the
criteria for the gates of heaven to be
open and the gates of hell to be closed
is that you have to
fast. And
furthermore, to enter Jenna, you require
a ticket.
The ticket to go to Jenna is mentioned
in the Quran in surah alsar chapter
number 103 verse number 1 to3 where
Allah
says that by the token of time man is
verily in a state of loss except those
who have faith. those who do righteous
deeds, those who exhort people to truth
and those who exalt people to patience
and perseverance. This surah according
to Imam Shafi he said that only if this
surah was to be revealed of the Quran it
would have been sufficient for the
salvation of mankind. So important is it
is called as rahijat the way for
salvation. And the criteria for any
human being to enter Jenna is four.
First is iman, second
is righteous deeds. Third is exorting
people to truth and fourth is exorting
people to patience and perseverance. So
here we realize that the gates of heaven
are open. But just because the gates
open, you can't enter. You require the
ticket. The ticket is iman. The ticket
is righteous deed. Exoding people to
truth, exorting people to patience and
perseverance and to get this ticket is
very easy in month of
Ramadan because the iman level rises in
the month of Ramadan. Furthermore, your
righteous deed the reward is
multiplied. It's easier. You can call
people to truth. Your patient level
increases. So this hadith means that you
have to have the criteria that inshallah
you should go to Jenna and you'll not go
to hell. That doesn't mean that 100%
people who die will go to Jenna. Surely
those who are non-believers, they have
got no iman. So there's no question that
they will enter
Jenna. If a person has to enter Jenna,
he requires a ticket. And the ticket to
Jenna is surah alam. Furthermore, if you
read the hadith, it says that only if
you fast in the month of
Ramadan, that means and you follow all
the rules and regulations and I pretend
from thing which are prohibited, then
the doors of heaven will be open and the
gates of hell will be closed.
Furthermore, it says in this month is a
night which is equivalent to more than
thousand months indicating that even if
you pray and worship to Allah subhanana
wa tala in this one night it will
equivalent to more than a thousand
months is about more than 80 years
imagine. So the chances for you to get
reward only in this one night is more
than a lifetime. An average human being
lives for 60 years. So
one is more than a thousand months is
about more than 80 years more than
average life of a human being. The
chances are very easy to go to Jenna.
And the ending part of the hadith says a
person who's
deprived of these blessings is truly a
deprived person indicating that everyone
will not go to Jenna, everyone will not
find the doors of heaven open. It says
the ending part very important that a
person who's deprived of the blessings
in this month is truly a deprived
person. That means telling us Muslims
that if you cannot get the benefits of
this month of Ramadan and then if you
cannot go to Jenna then you are truly a
deprived person that even includes the
non-Muslims who have they are truly the
deprived people.
So Dr.
Well, and I thank you for those
intriguing answers, particularly
pertaining to the last two questions
which you answer so eloquently,
mashallah. Hamill.